wie es jetzt läuft. Aha das sieht besser aus. Guck dir mal da es funktioniert. Easy. Easy.
Bisschen lauter Sound oder? Alter der Sound ist mega lauter. Twitch Routing Outplayed. Ok
funktioniert. Nice. Ich benutze übrigens jetzt den Service in Amsterdam. Was? Was ist jetzt los?
Was ist jetzt los? Ok ich glaube es funktioniert. Also danke Rede. Kurzer Sinn wir gucken uns jetzt
das neueste Battlefield Video an. Nochmal von vorne. Und wir machen das Video mal kurz mal hier den.
Auf gehts. Das Video ist total leise. Ok. Ja ich hab tatsächlich Zero Hour Enjoyed für zwei bis
drei Tage. Danach war die Luft raus. MonkaW. By the way wir reden hier davon. Die tut so als
wäre das wahnsinnig viel Content und sonst was. Das ist alles die gleiche Map. Ja also es ist jetzt
nicht so als wären das drei verschiedene Maps oder das erste war eine Portal Map. Ok das ist
alles die eine gleiche Map. Das ist auch die gleiche Map. Das ist die Portal Map. Das ist die
zwei Map. Und das alles in sechs Minuten zwanzig. Da bin ich mal gespannt. Also entweder gibt's da
nix oder da gehts jetzt wirklich Schlag auf Schlag. Da bin ich gespannt drauf. Ok Leute die schmeißen
die Specialists nicht raus. Ich sag euch wie es ist. Die schmeißen die nicht raus. Die Leute
hoffen das aber die schmeißen die nicht raus. Die zeigen es auch schon viel zu viel. Sind sie
doch schon? Hä? Moment. Sind sie doch schon? Die Specialists haben doch alle eine klassische
Battlefield Klasse associated. Haben sie doch schon? Ok mal angucken. Wie gesagt das sind sie
doch schon. Ich glaube es steht doch schon mittlerweile dran dass es ein Assault Specialist ist. Ah ok
das ist neu. Ok es gibt Traits die man aus... Ja gut aber das Gadget ist doch immer noch das
gleiche. Ich mein Webstar ist der Typ mit dem Grappling Hook. Sunnets ist die mit dem Wingsuit.
Die haben doch bestimmt nicht das neu modelliert und animiert das Webstar jetzt mit dem Wingsuit
rumfliegen kann. Das heißt diese Specialist Traits sind jetzt das was du sharen kannst.
Open Gadgets sind jetzt auch schon open. Ok ich mein ich finde das gut dass sie das mehr
sichtbar machen dass die jetzt schon wohlgemerkt jetzt schon eingeteilt sind in genau diese
Kategorien. Das ist ja nichts neues also diese die Specialist haben jetzt schon genau diese
Einteilung. Wobei ich mir bei den zwei gar nicht sicher bin ob die da überhaupt... Also wie gesagt
die haben jetzt also das hier sind Assaults. Das waren schon immer Assault Specialist. Maria
Falk war schon immer Support, Medic ja das ist nichts neues. Was jetzt anscheinend neu ist sind
Traits also sprich du kannst die Traits zwischen diesen drei Specialist dann sharen. Ok aber sag
man mal so das primäre von also diese die die also diese primären Sachen die Specialist ausmachen
also sprich dass er einen Grappling Hook hat und das jetzt muss ich aufpassen dass ich nichts
falsches sage ich glaube sie einen Wingsuit hat bzw. Fragmentation Granaten und sowas und dass
das er ein Schild hat hier das wird ja weiterhin so bleiben also eigentlich hat sich bis auf die
Traits nichts geändert oder sehe ich das falsch also im Prinzip ist es immer noch das gleiche.
Ich bin mal gespannt ich meine die die Season startet bald irgendwie in 14 Tagen oder so können
wir es ausprobieren aber wie gesagt ich also im Prinzip ist das mehr oder weniger das gleiche
bis auf die Traits. Die sind jetzt auch schon also diese Einteilung hier unten gibt es doch
jetzt auch schon das ist nichts neues ich bin mir nicht sicher ob es so dran steht aktuell schon
ich habe das Game auch nicht mehr installiert aber die Einteilung ist jetzt auch schon so ok
Nächstes Jahr! Nächstes Jahr! Nächstes Jahr! Keckl! Ich dachte das kommt jetzt mit Season 2 man! Nächstes
Jahr ok alles klar nice top! Season 3 man! Ok nicht nächstes Jahr vielleicht zu Weihnachten
oder so. Ich weiß nicht wann war Season 1 Release? Sekunde das muss ich mir jetzt gerade mal angucken.
Was ging das los? Ah ok vor drei Monaten. Das ist Ende des Jahres nächstes Jahr! Meine Güte
Alter was machen die den ganzen Tag? Ich finde das prinzipiell gut aber das ist jetzt keine
riesen Änderung ja weil wie gesagt die Specialist sind schon so gruppiert das ist rein eine optische
Sache jetzt kommen halt noch die Traits dazu die geshared werden können das finde ich prinzipiell
nice aber das macht aus dem Specialist System jetzt kein Klassen System wie es die Leute wollen
ja das stimmt ich finde die dinge die die Specialist sehen halt jetzt halt nicht aus
als passen in das Game wisst ihr aber was das größte Problem ist die Models sind schlicht
oder greif nicht fertig die haben ja kaum Details guckt euch das mal an die sehen alle aus die haben
alle falsche Beleuchtung irgendwie im Gesicht es sieht überhaupt nicht fertig fertig gemodelt
aus diese Dinger das ist das eigentliche Problem was ich mit den Specialist habe die sehen so aus
wie irgendwelche nicht ok Plays Halter Models ist jetzt zu hart du siehst schon dass da Leute
dran gesessen haben die wissen was sie machen ja aber die sehen halt einfach nicht fertig aus
Alter Boris mann Boris weint gleich was ist denn mit Boris los Alter Boris mann wisst ihr wisst ihr
wie Boris aussieht Boris sieht ein bisschen aus in diesem wenn er so als wieder Windows 11 Präsentator
kennt kennt kennt ihr noch die Windows 11
ich finde der neue Boris hat gewisse Ähnlichkeiten zu dem Windows 11 Präsentator oder ein bisschen
ein bisschen ähnlich sehen die sich schon ok guck mal fertig meine Maus legt chat wer von euch ist es
wer wer lässt meine Maus legen gibt zu gibt euch zu erkennen
der Schreiker ist es bestimmt der ist Kubernetes Admin die machen sowas
den aus Mauszeiger ja ok guck mal weiter
ok wer wirklich besser aussieht muss man sagen ist jetzt die die Radar Radar Specialist hin weil
das Modell von der fand ich dieser vorher dieser übrigens in game auch nicht so aus ne die hat in
game viel mehr Pausebäckchen Pausbäckchen gehabt als hier weil dieser wirklich unfertig aus das
sieht tatsächlich das hat irgendwie auch ein paar Kanten so und ansonsten haben sie den einfach ein
bisschen bisschen Dreck ins Gesicht geschmiert und das ist jetzt halt viel besser und dunkler und so
das war es mit den Prime Abos MonkaS
also wenn in dem Tempo weitermachen kriegen wir tatsächlich alle vier
dinger man muss halt mal sagen mit Gameplay hatte das bis jetzt noch relativ wenig zu tun es gibt
jetzt halt im Prinzip genau das gleiche wie vorher nur noch zusätzlich Specialist Trades die
man in der gleichen Klassen Kategorie scheren kann ok ja das ist schon core Gameplay das passt
wann kommen Klaasers zurück gar nicht hat sie gerade gesagt dass die Battlefield 3 M16 auch
mit dem Ding hinten dran zwei zwei Waffen plus noch mal zwei aus dem Season Update das heißt
vier Waffen und zwei davon sind alt ich mein gut dass es mehr Waffen gibt das Spiel hat prinzipiell
deutlich zu wenig Waffen wir dürfen nicht vergessen das ist aber Sachen Portal Content die seit
Release im Prinzip drinne ist also dafür müssen die gar nichts machen das ist alles schon da
jetzt bin ich tatsächlich mal gespannt weil wenn sie in dem Tempo weitermachen habe ich
ausgerechnet was ich was ich nicht mit eingerechnet habe ist die DLC Maps aber von denen gehen wir
ein oder die Season Maps von denen gehen wir einfach mal von aus dass die gescheit sind ich
habe das mal vorhin ausgerechnet also wenn die in dem Tempo weitermachen wie sie jetzt weitermachen
dann haben wir in eineinhalb Jahren nach Release ungefähr die Launch Maps in einem brauchbaren
Zustand es ist jetzt nicht so dass diese Anpassung wahnsinnig große Ressourcenfresser sind ich
meine diese diese Container sind die gleichen Container die sie seit Battlefield 2 haben oder
so und hier die haben sie hier wahnsinnig viele tolle neue Assets für bauen müssen dass das
funktioniert aber wisst ihr was man finde ich an diesem Ausschnitt wirklich gut erkennt guckt
euch das mal an was man hieran sieht ist die mehr die Maps die waren schlicht und ergreifend nicht
fertig zu Release meine das ist glaube ich mittlerweile jedem klar dass das Game zu Release
nicht fertig die Maps waren schlicht und ergreifend nicht nicht fertig so sieht das deutlich mehr nach
einer Battlefield Map aus ich finde es halt ein bisschen schade dass man jetzt den einfachsten
Weg gewählt hat und dort irgendwelche Gerüste Kisten und Sandsäcke hinstellt aber nicht dass
du trotz ich meine es passt zum Szenario aber ansonsten es ist einfach es fehlt einfach alles
an Details auf dieser Map an Deckung an guter Spielbarkeit eben dadurch dass du über so viele
offene Flächen liefst ja und auch guckt euch den Boden an der Boden sah halt einfach immer viel zu
viel zu sauber und unfertig aus also du siehst einfach die Dinger waren nie fertig zu nie und
immer fertig zu release alle Maps brauchen den Overhaul
orbital orbital ist die Map mit der Rakete die sie am Anfang so ausführlich gezeigt haben weil
es die einzige Map war die irgendwie ein cooles Feature hatte so mit der Rakete jetzt siehst du
halt mal richtig diese Maps waren nie fertig das könnte jetzt eins zu eins irgendwie so eine Base
in Firestorm oder so sein die Maps waren nicht fertig die waren mitten in der die wurden mitten
aus der Entwicklung gerissen und released es ist jetzt bestimmt nicht der super geilste Weg da
überall Kisten hinzustellen wie gesagt es passt ja wahrscheinlich haben sie die sich gerade noch
im Unreal Asset Store gekauft und importiert weil Kisten und Salzsäcke findest du bestimmt zu
genüge aber ich meine jetzt sieht das jetzt jetzt sieht das irgendwie nach einer normalen
Battlefield Map aus ja es ist das jetzt ist das ok jetzt jetzt hat es auch geblieben guck mal du
hast jetzt auch zum ersten mal so ein bisschen Details teilweise auf der Straße also das ist
schon in Ordnung ja so das sieht ich meine es ist die billigste Variante überhaupt ja mit
mit diesen Kisten und Containern und Planken und Warnhütchen und so aber so stelle ich mir
eher eine Battlefield Map vor aber was halt was halt da auch immer mich ein bisschen verwirrt
ist ich mein warum braucht man da acht Monate für
es ist jetzt ja kein großer Akt da Kisten hinzustellen oder so das machst du jetzt mal
in zwei Wochenenden Container machen keinen Sinn das ist korrekt deswegen ist ja das ist die
billigste Variante das erinnert mich an Half-Life Maps falls jemand Half-Life Maps von früher noch
kennt ganz viele Half-Life Maps hatten Container und Kisten und Blöcke und sowas und das lag
daran weil Half-Life halt selbst saumäßig viele Kisten Blöcke und Absperrungen und Container
mitgebracht hat weil eben das Half-Life Szenario vieles hatte dass ganz viele Maps die die Leute
erstellt haben bestanden zu 80 prozent aus Containern weil halt die Asset schon drin waren und
es sieht tatsächlich ein bisschen aus wie eine Half-Life Map die Container an der Stelle machen
überhaupt keinen Sinn man hätte wenn man sich wirklich also das hier unten finde ich okay das
ist quasi so eine Befestigung für diesen Punkt das ist in Ordnung was ist eigentlich mit der
Straßenaufschrift war die ja die war vorher da das ist okay was ich halt hier die Container ergeben
tatsächlich relativ wenig Sinn hätte man die Map vielleicht ein bisschen anders gebaut anders hätte
man da auch was anderes machen können aber den ist halt den drei Leuten die da noch dran arbeiten
ist halt nichts eingefallen aber mir ist es so immer noch lieber als im Standardzustand
die haben die haben eine Konzeptzeichnung gebraucht wie jeden Container wahrscheinlich
ja sonst deswegen hat es so lange gedauert. Hey das sieht jetzt mal irgendwie nach einem
Untergrund aus den irgendjemand nicht aus einem Random Generator raus hat sondern sich auch mal
bisschen was überlegt hat bei ja man könnte Klohäuschen hinstellen zum Beispiel was halt
hier von Klohäuschen Klohäuschen sind eh wahnsinnig unterrepräsentiert auf diesen Maps finde ich
Klohäuschen und natürlich bitte schön auch drei weil MWD das muss schon alles korrekt sein
ist überall die selbe Nummer auf den Containern wirklich tatsächlich ist mir gar nicht aufgefallen
171 gut man kann halt sagen das ist der Hersteller oder so aber ja es ist das ist schon billig ich
bin mal gespannt was sie uns zu neuem Content zeigen. By the way die haben noch nichts von
Season 2 gezeigt das hier ist jetzt quasi der Rework der mit Season 2 kommt aber wir haben noch
nichts gesehen von Season 2 zumal Season 2 noch glaube ich in 14 Tagen oder so fast schon startet
oder drei Wochen ich meine das hätte man schon da hätte man schon ein bisschen kreativer sein
können ich meine das ist ja irgendein Bürogebäude ja dann hätte man was weiß ich Schränke
irgendwelche alten Computersachen oder was auch immer dafür sind Map Designer da. Mein Kisten
ist halt wirklich das einfachste was du machen kannst. Ich meine es ist Battlefield deswegen
passt es halbwegs noch dass man so befestigte Stellung macht. Ist okay. Ja ich mein man hätte
ja durchaus man hätte also wenn man sich Mühe gegeben hätte es gibt ja wenn ich mir jetzt mal
recht wenn ich mir mal wirklich recht Gedanken mache man hätte da schon machen können ja man
hätte zum Beispiel hier einen Fahrstuhl hin machen können der Fahrstuhl ist aber hier durch
die Decke gebrochen oder irgendwie sowas ja man hätte beispielsweise dann Deckung machen können
keine Ahnung hier ist was durchs Fenster gecrasht und liegt jetzt hier oder wisst ihr sowas der
hätte man halt ein bisschen bisschen mehr Aufwand gebraucht und ein bisschen mehr sich Gedanken machen
müssen oder es wäre dann halt auch nicht mit mit Copy Paste bestehender Sachen getan gewesen man
hätte guckt mal zum Beispiel so ein Ding hier ja so ein Ding hier hätte man hier hinstellen können
auf der einen Seite kaputt machen und hier rein brechen lassen können durchs Dach zum Beispiel
sowas also oder oder ein paar irgendwas da gäbe es durchaus Möglichkeiten wenn man gewollt hätte
ok hier sieht man eine Sache gut dran was mich schon immer gestört hat seit Release auf den
Battlefield Maps auf den Battlefield 2042 Maps diese Maps sahen viel zu clean aus für Battlefield
Maps guckt euch das mal an die sahen deutlich zu clean aus so ist das tatsächlich finde ich
deutlich besser wobei man halt sagen muss das sind dann auch wieder nur Kisten und Sandsäcke
im Endeffekt aber ok es sieht schon besser also sieht naja besser ich weiß nicht ob wir besser
denken besser aber ich meine dass man zumindest mal Spuren und ein bisschen Details auf den Straßen
hat ist schon ist schon die Sandsäcke sind hier passt aus alles da
dass sie das ist besser das ist besser ich weiß macht zwar keinen Sinn dass die Sandsäcke und
konnte ok das sieht jetzt wenigstens mal aus nach irgendwas wo was gearbeitet wurde ja wo was
passiert ist und nicht einfach nur nach einer ungefährte unfertigen Map der Sinn dieses Tunnels
hier hat sich immer noch entschlossen da diese Halo Tunnel wo man mit dem Auto durchfährt
die haben so viele Container auf ihren Maps die haben sogar schon Kubernetes hast recht
cloud native Battlefield warum schaut man sich das noch an du meinst warum ich mir das Video
anschaue oder warum es immer noch leute gibt die das spielen also ich denke mal das liegt daran
dass leute das noch spielen weil es viele leute gibt wie ich die gerne Battlefield spielen und
hoffen dass da mal was gescheites kommt Video anschauen da weil ich wissen will was ich da
tut wir haben den Kram alle gekauft und ich finde es tatsächlich immer noch spannend was da
rauskommt ich habe die Hoffnung zwar aufgegeben dass da am Ende wirklich was gutes spielbares
rauskommt aber es interessiert mich trotzdem was rauskommt und sei es nur dass ich drüber
lästern kann dass nichts gescheites rauskommt. Moment die Türme sind weg
man hat einfach alles man hat einfach steht da auch überall 71 auf den Containern das
würde ich jetzt gerne sehen ob da überall 71 drauf steht wie auf den anderen Containern
ich mein das ist halt wirklich sehr billig muss man sagen das ist wirklich billig
guck dir das ist wirklich billig ich meine die haben einfach ganz viele Dinger genommen und
wild hier drüber copypasted man muss sagen ja man sieht sie haben sich ein bisschen Gedanken
gemacht es hat schon mal zumindest einer kurz fünf Minuten überlegt wie hier Sachen platziert sind
man gescheite Deckung von hier nach hier hast immer noch nicht aber vielleicht will man das auch nicht
du siehst es hat sich schon eine Gedanken gemacht hier kannst du eindeutig drübergucken vermute
ich mal bin mir gar nicht so sicher aber wenn gehe ich mal was rübergucken ein und seit ab
hier drüben auch hier kannst du rausgucken hier kannst du zumindest relativ schnell ja also hat
es mal zumindest einer sich ein bisschen Gedanken drüber gemacht aber die Umsetzung ist halt wirklich
billig die Umsetzung ist wirklich billig da wurde einfach nur krass copypasted as fuck
was hältst du von clash auf ernsthaft nix mobile crap alter
ne nix mit mobile games kannst du mich nicht schocken
the removal of those two as capture points we've added a new capture point on 128 layer hast du
kein handy ich habe sogar drei handys aber da kommt kein mobile game drauf stimmt gar nicht
vier sind ja mittlerweile hier sind ja sogar weird flex ja sind ja sogar vier mittlerweile
128 layout aber ich benutze davon nur eins on the hills giving more to fight over between the crawl
away and refinery on the refinery side was passiert da unten mit dem gras leute was passiert
guckt euch mal das gras an was passiert hier gerade mit dem gras und refinery ist das level of detail
sachen die rein ploppen oder man sieht man sieht so in der animation gescheit in the crawl away
and refinery an die settings hätte man ja für die videoaufnahme mal wenigstens umstellen können
seit wann ist kein das ist so weil es weil ich das jetzt so entschieden habe allerdings
lull weh ist immer noch das unangefochten beste lach emote
was benutzt als main handy an iphone 11 warum warum kann ich dir ganz einfach sagen weil
ich das von der firma gestellt bekommen und ich selbst kaufen muss
lull e zwar ein lull was hat lull e lull e ffz nee das ist ein forsen emote
lull p ist zu krass
gucken wir mal gibt es gar nicht
was soll das sein
doch gibt es
ok komm moment jetzt bin ich mal gespannt was machen sie denn hier jetzt hier stehen
noch schon so viele container lasst mich raten sandsäcke und und beton blöcke
sandsäcke und beton blöcke wer hätte das machen können und mehr container wird aber langsam eng
für neue neuen content den sonst zeigen wollen die area changing up the sightlines to improve
the infantry experience and adding tighter barriers to slow down vehicles kisten und beton blöcke
hey mal wirklich strukturelle änderungen an der map prog dafür musste der entwickler von
einem anderen game abgezogen werden dafür wahrscheinlich das hat der praktikant allein
nicht alleine hinbekommen es gibt tatsächlich neue laufwege das finde ich gut die beleuchtung
sieht auch deutlich besser aus guckt euch das immer an hier so und jetzt mit dem hier finde
ich sieht deutlich stimmiger aus ja das ist das ist gut guckt guckt euch diese map an es kann mir
doch keiner sagen diese map war fertig zu release die sind so steril und unfertig aus und jetzt
passt auf jetzt kommen jede menge container dazu aber ok man immerhin besser als als nix ja moment
es kam noch ein loch in der straße dazu nicht nur container es kam container in mengen dazu aber es
kaum auch ein loch in der straße dazu das konnten sie aber wahrscheinlich auch copy pasten von
irgendwo anders kriegst helping to keep guck mal hier auf dem runway sind jetzt jede menge kaputte
panzer und löcher Leute das sind doch alles die gleichen löcher das sind exakt die gleichen
löcher das sind alles die klein oder oder dass die gleichen löcher alles oder haben sie die
leicht variiert intensity high that these two infantry heavy flags with adjustments to the nearby
terrain helping to make sure ok ich sag nix das sind nicht alles die gleichen löcher die copy
pasted werden oder you can attack these flags from more angles than before but our main focus for
the map has been helping to improve cover and combat across the crawl away with a lot
ja das sieht jetzt schon sehr sehr gezwungen aus hier also sehr so fack wir mussten was machen wir
wissen nicht was wir machen sollen also das ist einfach ja ich meine es sieht besser aus wie
es sieht jetzt mehr nach einer battlefield map aus ja aber da hätte man doch so viel mehr machen
können wenn man wenn man sich mühe gegeben hätte man hätte vielleicht teile vom haus
einstürzen lassen können also schon im vorfeld die da drüber liegen oder vielleicht irgendwelche
lk man könnte ja beispielsweise wunderbar ein lkw hin machen der eine der eine raketenstufe
beispielsweise zum launchpad zieht oder so und kaputt ist belegt euch das mal nehmt ihr irgendwie
so eine so eine so eine raketenstufe legt ihr auf ein lkw sowas hier legt ihr auf ein lkw transporter
und lasst den mal mit so einem doppelten transporter legt die launchstufe ist ja nach hier vorne das
launchpad ist ja nach hier vorne und da hätte man den hier platzieren können in der mitte das
hätte irgendwie gepasst dann hätte man sich vielleicht hier überlegen können vielleicht
macht mir nicht einfach einen hügel hin sondern man setzt das haus ein bisschen vor ja solche
sachen also ich denke mit ein bisschen mehr engagement hätte man da das deutlich schöner
machen können als das rein copy paste ich sehe schon komm ich muss glaube ich morgen neues video
dazu machen und da werde ich mir den hasse der paar verbliebenen battlefield fans wieder zuziehen
aber ok was sei es drum ich meine es ist ja wahr es ist es ist ja wahr kann ja keiner gibt's ja
nichts groß weg zu diskutieren kann ja keiner wirklich behaupten das wäre hier peak peak map
design das mag für die spielbarkeit auf jeden fall gut sein aber bei gutes map design heißt
spielbarkeit und optik geht hand in hand das ist ein bisschen was was beispielsweise die
valorant maps die die ich kenne die ich gesehen habe nicht gut hinbekommen die mögen spielbar
sein aber die gehen nicht gut hand in hand mit der umgebung so was ist twitter post von was
so ein work in progress changes
ja das haben wir gerade schon gesehen
ist das eigentlich so schwer in der engine was umzubauen also ich kann dir nur meinen
noob eindruck da jetzt sagen weil keiner von uns hat hier mit frostbite gearbeitet aber ganz
im ernst wenn es so schwer wäre da was drinne zu platzieren dann könnten sie darin keine games
entwickeln ich meine vielleicht sind die tools nicht so geil wie man das aus aus unreal oder
so kennt aber ich aber mal ein vergleich ein vergleich ich habe früher gerne half life maps
gemacht ich war nie wirklich so krass gut dass meine maps irgendwo gespielt wurden oder so ja
aber ich habe gerne half life maps gemacht einfach weil ich es cool fand zu sehen was
man selbst bauen kann und das hättest du damals in worldcraft nannte sich das in half life an
nichts mehr mit minecraft zu tun worldcraft das hast du damals in worldcraft in paar minuten
gemacht sowas gar nicht ob es da gescheite gescheite bild davon gibt ja guck hier kisten
luftung schächte also was hast du auch ein paar hast du auch in paar minuten gemacht damals im
half life editor hier solche dinge platziert und wenn du sowas damals schon easy as fuck gemacht
hast natürlich nicht auf solchen riesen riesen das ist der eins zu eins cscone zwischenteilig
hatten ihren hammer editor nicht weiß gar nicht wie das jetzt heißt tatsächlich das sieht immer
noch so aus ja damals ist das worldcraft und da wie gesagt ich hab ich hab gerne half life
maps gemacht damals und dort fertige assets zu platzieren war easy copy paste blub blub blub
moment ich muss die musik ausmachen sonst äußerst verwirrend wenn mario musik im hintergrund läuft
die können keine mod tools freigeben die haben keine mod tools die haben nur ihre eigenen tools
und die sind glaube ich so scheiße da drin will keiner mods entwickeln spiele wo das gut funktioniert
sind so sachen wie beispielsweise half life 1 und 2 weil die die tools die sie verwendet haben um
das spiel zu entwickeln auch als mod tools released haben bzw wahrscheinlich schon in
der entwicklung auch ein bisschen darauf geachtet haben dass die tools später freigegeben werden
soll ich glaube mit den frostbite tools will von uns keiner was entwickeln was hältst du von einer
portfolio webseite das ist jetzt so ziemlich aus dem nichts aber für was für dienstleistung die
du anbietest oder wie oder was oder dann mach also verstehe ich nicht was soll ich dazu sagen wenn
du was verkaufen willst oder werbung für dich machen will sicher dass mit sicherheit sinnvoll
was aber sinnvoller ist falls du jobs suchst oder so mit sicherheit ist ein ordentliches link in
profil ansonsten weiß nicht keine ahnung
ka
ja finde ich schon sinnvoll finde ich also wenn man was zum wenn man was vor
zeigbares hat und vielleicht das auch mal sagen wir für im weiteren sinn gefasst für
seine karriere einsetzungen klar warum nicht das finde ich schon sinnig ja die renn oh leute es
hat sich an der map struktur was fährt random fragen ist kein ding random fragen ich mag random
fragen manchmal verstehe ich den zusammenhang nicht was die leute genau wissen was guck mal
tatsächlich tatsächlich änderung an der map struktur da liegt jetzt irgendwie so eine so
eine geöffnete dose oder so weiß ich genau was hat immer ein plan was das sein soll bestimmt
copy pasted von einer anderen map ok um diese rege um dieses areal mit container ist es sicherlich
nicht schade abgestürzte kapsel vielleicht ja
vielleicht oder abgestürzte kapsel die vorne auf der rakete drauf ist es könnte tatsächlich
so in so ein mcdonalds deckel sein von der cola es ist nachts kälter als draußen boah das ist ja
das ist ja die oldschooligste tschübait frage die ist ja die hat ja schon hätte schon kinder
gekriegt die tschüb diese frage die ist die ist ja schon so alt
aber das finde ich so musst du es machen so hätten sie es überall machen müssen
dass die map struktur halt sinnvoll irgendwie geändert so ist das ok ja man hat jetzt hier
so einen kleinen so eine kleine schlucht und hier so das ist das ist eine gute map änderung da
hat mal der map designer beziehungsweise der mapper wie man das sonst so genannt hat mal
tatsächlich bock gehabt jetzt bin ich aber mal gespannt wie sie in eineinhalb stunden uns
experiences und new modes und new content zeigen wollen da kommt wahrscheinlich jetzt gar nichts
da kommt wahrscheinlich einfach nur wir arbeiten an neuem content keckel und tschüss
eineinhalb minuten das ist jetzt kommt season 2 aber container haben sie da auch ordentlich
drin oder ich meine irgendwann ist es mal gut mit container eine container base ist
feifett aber immerhin ein paar nette particle effekte wo auch beide wei leute blöde frage
warum wo kommen die her warum kommen da irgendwelche partikel runter ist da oben
irgendwie stahl was gegossen wird oder warum fallen hier so partikel runter mehr container
alter leute jetzt über leute warum warum sind auf den container pflanzen drauf was ist das für
eine map was sehe ich da das ist doch keine map jetzt mal ernsthaft ich mein manifest besteht
zur hälfte schon aus container am anfang ja aber warum sind es noch mehr container alter und warum
stehen da einfach random kleine palmen und bäume auf den container man habe ich gesehen also
sekunde das haben wir jetzt gesehen das haben wir gesehen und das ist jetzt noch mal so ein
typischer gang der eins zu eins aus moment ist das überhaupt die neue map oder ist das manifest
rework leute habt ihr das mitbekommen ist das die neue map oder ist das vielleicht manifest im
rework
das ist die neue map oder das ist die neue map guckt euch mal die die fässer da wo sind
wir ist das das ikea waren lager oder wo sind wir hier ich meine schwedische entwickler würde
jetzt ja kann ja kann ja sein und da sieht es bestimmt so aus
und was ist hier hinter den container noch mehr container sehe ich das richtig das ist
ein k.i. map generator der das gemacht hat bestimmt wer würde container so stapeln vor
allem dinger die da rausgucken das ist eine wirklich gut berechtigte frage was ist das da
im hintergrund so und das ist irgendwie so was wie von die rail oder wie die map heißt nie
wie heißt die map die rail war eine mw2 map das ist also so ein schiffskorridor wo mal
tatsächlich andere formen von containern rumstehen und half life kisten oder ist das jetzt im
container sind jetzt im container drin es gibt es sieht aus wie auf kaleidoskop hier ein bisschen
ja moment ja jetzt habt ihr noch eine minuten zeit für experiences und new content jetzt kommt
das war es mit experiences und new content das wurde jetzt mal kurz so ja übrigens leute hier
gibt es ein paar neue container auf der neuen map das ist jetzt experiences und new content
bam auf geht's next experiences und mode ok new content achtung eine minuten zeit noch wir sehen
hier alle da ist mit arbeiter die nicht an battlefield 2042 arbeiten ist ja was ist ja
das spielt bestimmt gerade battlefield 4 und deswegen haben sie es geblatt oder bf1
das war jetzt new content oder was zu sagen wir machen gerade ganz viel
neuer content wir können euch zwar nach acht monaten noch keinen richtigen neuen content
zeigen aber wir machen gerade ganz vielen neuen content skorpi danke für den sup ja ja ja was
halte ich davon ich mein gut dass sie überhaupt was machen ansonsten halt wirklich minimalst
leistung was man erbringt dort ja ja weiß gar nicht was ich da groß zu sagen soll also
ist jetzt nicht dass ich wirklich dass ich übelst ausrasten würde über das update ich gucke mir
season 2 und die neue map auf jeden fall an leute wir gucken uns das auch auf jeden fall
im stream zusammen an wenn es denn dann soweit ist ob das dadurch in irgendeiner art und weise
wirklich größeren also widerspielwert bekommt ich weiß nicht aber ich sag euch wie es das
war sich schon seit monaten quasi schon seit ein paar wochen nach wie ich sage die liefern
halt das absolut mindeste mindeste ab gerade mit den seasons dass sie nicht verklagt werden
können im zweifelsfall und dann kommt irgendwann das nächste battlefield und dann können wir
nur hoffen dass das nächste battlefield besser wird vielleicht vielleicht ich meine die hoffnung
stirbt ja zuletzt ja vielleicht musste battlefield 2042 einfach mal so richtig ins klo greifen dass
das nächste battlefield die chance hat besser zu werden wie gesagt kopium hoch 3 aber vielleicht
ist es ja so wann kommt es raus ich glaube in zwei oder drei wochen kommt die nächste season
übrigens das was du in dem video gesehen hast die helfe davon kommt ja erst mit season 3
level cap stellt das vor new huge game changing massive neugigkeiten oder so
ja portal juckt ja anscheinend auch nicht mehr genau was ist denn season 2 bf release
update ich glaube irgendwann anfangen september haben die gesagt oder nicht am ersten
genau die am anfang september gesagt deswegen sage ich ja die nächsten zwei wochen vielleicht
oder die nächsten zwei drei wochen hat es wenigstens einem gefallen das ergibt jetzt
auch sinn warum die warum die container so komisch angeordnet waren der orchestrator hat
nicht so richtig orchestrated wisst ihr was dem spiel wirklich gut tun würde was aber zu
wenig ja wie soll ich sagen zu wenig bringt unterm strich und und sicherlich auch zu viel
auffangen ist ein ordentlicher soundtrack würde dem spiel wirklich gut tun ich meine hört euch
mal an nur mal so wir machen mal kurz den vergleich nicht bfbf eins er hört euch zum
beispiel das hier an es geht jetzt erst los ja wartet mal bis das richtig los geht das ist
richtig gut das soundtrack bf eins jetzt ja das dauert kurz bis es halt ist halt menü ist
halt menü sound aber hört sich wirklich ein bisschen nach hans zimmer an aber ist
wahrscheinlich nicht die partys können das ja auch das hat richtig gut das soundtrack
jetzt jetzt das finde ich das hat was das hat wirklich was also oder auch später dann
das hat richtig melodie und passt atmosphärisch zum game
so jetzt haltet euch fest haltet euch fest jetzt haltet euch fest achtung
das ist richtig gut das soundtrack ja von bf eins
und jetzt achtung achtung ordn zu halten ordn zu halten
so was würde ich mir vorstellen wenn irgendwie einer versucht meine übertragung zu meine
funk übertragung zu jam dann würde er zu zu stören dann würde er sowas spielen ja
kaige kaige generated soundtrack also ich gehe davon aus dass es hildur günners dort hier
und sam slater sicherlich besser können hört euch das an mann was ist das das tut weh was ist
das also ich mein wer hat das partys gehört hat sich gedacht das ist es das ist der soundtrack
für unser game und und verdankt und und verdankt dass es besser wird guckt es immer mehr wer denkt
dass es besser wird monkels alter alter
was ist das ich mein wir dürfen nicht vergessen passt mal auf wir dürfen nicht vergessen die haben
mal soundtracks geschrieben wieso was hier
die können das ja die können das ja aber in 2042 können die das nicht
ich weiß nicht ich weiß nicht leute keine ahnung was mit den schweden abgeht in dem fall unverständlich
ja es hört sich wirklich so an als haben die den soundtrack in einem der container aufgenommen
die da so rum steht genau so hört sich das an und im hintergrund sind noch ein paar sachen
runtergefallen genauso hört sich an leute gebt euch mal ein ruck noch vier follows bis 21.000
follower noch zwei follows bis keine subscriber follows follows also follows follows kosten
ja nur wirklich nix hier wer noch nicht gefollowed hat haut rein wahrscheinlich kommt jetzt gleich
wahrscheinlich sind es gleich wieder fünf oder so der erste hat wirklich an follow follow
danach hat er gleich wieder folgst du hättest das noch nicht mal sagen müssen ich wahrscheinlich
warst du es noch nicht mal wahrscheinlich warst du es noch nicht mal und sagst jetzt einfach dir
traue ich das direkt zu das passt einfach alter jetzt haben wirklich fünf leute entfollowed
macht was ihr wollt alter ich gehe jetzt auf habt ihr jetzt davon ich gehe jetzt wirklich
auf weil bettgetheim boomer müde gleich 22 uhr flow dankeschön für den sub bettgetheim
wegen jemand hosten ja ich muss tatsächlich morgen arbeiten den den sprecher haben wir
glaube ich letztes mal schon gehostet na gut alles klar leute wir sehen uns macht es gut
bis denn bis zum nächsten mal zu und dann nächstes mal ist progas angesagt wieder bis
denn zu